as i mentioned before this is a two-part
question and i want you to in groups
have a look at part two together i have
many different ways to solve this
question and i want you to see i'm going
to give you as promised a full 10
minutes in your rooms to try and find as
many solutions as you can so
i want you to
find a few methods
think about all of the knowledge you
have within complex geometry
complex number geometry i should say
you've got a lot of tools in your
toolbox and once you've come up with a
few solutions i want you to think about
which solutions you prefer and why so
give me a moment to set up the breakout
rooms so welcome back everyone um thank
you for having a go and playing with
that question um this is i think it's a
delightful question i know several of
you struggled with it and i hope that
means for you it's like oh this is a
very good indication that there's
something to learn here or i just
haven't looked at complex numbers enough
recently and i can't remember how to do
this admittedly part of why this
question is challenging is not just that
it's complex numbers but that it's
intertwined with circle geometry which
maybe is something you like oh i
definitely know why i have not revised
that frequently
you still have a bit of time up your
sleeve right but what i want to remind
you of is that circle geometry is one of
the topics that spacing it out in terms
of your revision is one of the most
helpful things so
if you've got like um you know your
revision plan set out i would make sure
that you are sort of you know not not
doing like one big chunk of i'm just
going to do three days straight on
circle geometry i'd intersperse it and
just do a question here or a question
there and hopefully this serves as sort
of a prompt for you to do that okay
now what i'm going to do is we've got um
17 minutes left in the timetabled lesson
and i'm not sure how we're going to go
in terms of getting these all of these
solution methods out i'm obviously i'm
not going to write all of this because
it would be completely impractical for
you to try and follow along but what i'm
going to ask you to do is something a
bit tricky here okay
i'm going to um
to ensure like i was talking with um
some of the people who were earlier
today more prompt with the lesson but
one of the tricky things we want to
communicate is not just
like i can solve it i can find the
center i can find the radius but also
that my reasoning is communicated very
clearly so for that reason everything
you're about to see
i have to say this cautiously everything
you're about to see i will provide you
i've got this in a pdf and i'll just
upload it onto canvas so i don't want
you to stress out trying to keep up with
every line of working that i'm going to
write because i will go through it far
too quickly for you to do that
however what i don't want you to do is
to say oh great i'm going to get all of
this notation and all of the reasoning
fully laid out later on i'm just going
to write nothing or i'm just going to
kind of sit back and not really think
too hard if that's what you do
i promise you you will get zero out of
what i'm about to explain to you right
because
hopefully you better follow it but when
you come back later you will have no
memory of why you like why one line
followed from another and that's because
if you're not thinking hard and
concentrating then no learning is
occurring right it all depends on what's
actually going on in your brain not
what's going on in my brain okay
so here's what i would advise with the
knowledge that you're going to get this
full working later on don't freak out
about every line but perhaps on these
copies of the diagram that you have
drawn i'd like you to follow along with
the reasoning for me okay and if you can
follow along each part of why this angle
becomes this angle or why this length
becomes this length i think that will
help you think through what's going on
last note of caution before i start off
on these solutions
i probably won't
get through all of these solutions so at
8 30 i will pause and if you want to
duck off you are welcome to
go have a break um i don't know what you
know other classes are doing and whether
they are
some of them are running live lessons i
know and it depends on your timetable
but for those of you who want to stick
around past 8 30 with me to have a look
at all of the solutions you're welcome
to the people who need to go you'll get
them on the recording okay
so
with all of those caveats mentioned uh
let's have a go at this question
together part two find the center and
radius of the circle i'm going to give
you all of the reasons um and we're
going to have a look at a few different
ways to get them okay
the first thing i'm going to comment on
which i referred to earlier is that this
diagram which they provided to us
is not that good um and so as a reason
you have to be very careful about using
the diagram um and reasoning from it
based on things that you think you can
see on the diagram versus things they've
actually told you okay now let me make a
case for why this diagram is not very
good can you see this length o a here
it's supposed to be 2 right
from the origin up to a is meant to you
know i'm going along the imaginary axis
to 2i so that's why this length here is
going to be 2 units okay now if you have
a look at this length over here it's
supposed to be 2 root 3. now root 3 is
about 1.7 so therefore 2 root 3 is
something like 3.4 3.5 ish right
now when you have a look even a very
cursory look at this diagram i'm going
to cheat and
to make it very obvious how inaccurate
this diagram is if you have a look at
trying to use the scale that's been
established on the vertical axis so if i
draw a circle here
so this circle
let's uh make it so you can see through
it that would help wouldn't it there we
go
and let's make it a bit thicker okay
there we go
so if i make that small enough so it
fits there okay so this is a circle with
radius 2 so you can see oops i needed a
bit bigger you can see where it hits the
real axis right here apparently that's
two units right and then if i go
that same distance again let's just
duplicate this
you can see if i go that same distance
again so i've got two units here then
i've got another two units here then
i've got another two units here ish so
you can see on the scale of this you're
like that's six units that's not even in
the ballpark of the 3.4 that it's
supposed to be so as a consequence what
i'm trying to point out is that you
cannot rely on this diagram even when
they don't say it's too scale you have
to assume it's not to scale but that
then calls into question everything else
that you can see on the diagram like are
things really as they appear now one of
the
crucial pieces that i'm going to use is
the fact that this line or this point
here a
or rather this line oh a is actually
tangent to this circle it looks tangent
doesn't it like there's a single point
of intersection there's another another
point somewhere on the imaginary axis
that intersects with this circle or with
the major arc okay
but just because it looks like that if
you have a look carefully at the word in
the question it doesn't actually tell
you that it's tangent to the imaginary
axis you kind of have to infer that from
the diagram which i just pointed out is
not very good okay so here's how you can
actually prove that yes this oa um you
know the imaginary axis is tangent to
the circle that's going to be important
for me because all of my reasoning is
going to rely on that fact okay
let's uh call this method one using the
imaginary axis as a tangent because
there are actually other ways that you
can solve this without that and i'll get
to them shortly okay
firstly i'm going to say azb from part
one um we proved that it was pylon three
and as i was mentioning to i think
emanuel asked the question right even if
you can't prove part one yourself if you
don't wanna surrender all the marks of
this question if it appeared in an exam
you can say yeah i'm just going to
assume that it's it's going to be a zb
um it's going to be pound 3 from what
you told me okay
if i know that that is true i'm going to
reason from that to then say okay ao and
bo i can say that there's going to be a
right angle in here because they're the
coordinate axes
on the real and the imaginary axis there
so that's fine i'm going to have 90
degrees there so then i can go back to
this
triangle that i highlighted before in
orange triangle aob right i can still do
right angle triangle trig in here
knowing that it's a triangle even if i
don't know like is there another point
that i intersect with the circle this
reasoning i'm about to doesn't have
anything to do with the circle it's just
looking at the triangle okay so what i
can say is in this triangle i'm going to
make that same argument that i made
before about tan of bao
and i can say that that's equal to root
3 so you can see i'm sort of rehearsing
some logic that i used before and i can
say this is important
since it's acute that angle b-a-o
sorry this angle up here in the corner
right that's acute so i didn't work this
out before
i'm using um opposite
sides to what i used before right i i
treated this as opposite and this is
adjacent earlier to find out this angle
um but now i'm treating ob as the
opposite and or a as the adjacent so
therefore the angle i'm going to get is
pi on 3 okay so i'll pop that in here i
think i can just squeeze that in pi on
three
now the reason why this is important is
because this shows that the angle i had
to prove in part one and this angle out
here they're equal to each other right a
z b and b bao are the same magnitude now
you might say
why do i care about this but others of
you might have the circle geometry
properties ticking in your mind these
two angles here are not just
incidentally related they actually if
you have a look here this angle between
this
this line here which i don't know
whether it's a tangent yet because they
haven't told me
and this chord it equals the angle over
here it's what we call the angle in the
alternate segment right there's one
segment over here that's jammed between
this uh line and this chord and then
there's the uh the other segment over
here where this angle a zb is sitting
right
so if you've got these angles in one
segment and the other being equal to
each other that's what shows that this
is a tangent so
this is the angle in the alternate
segment theorem i accidentally deleted
some of my letters here the angle in the
alternate segment theorem tells us that
that line if it's a tangent is going to
create this equal angle in the alternate
segment and the converse is also true so
that's what i'm taking advantage of here
to prove that o a is tangent right
if o a is tangent then it's um the whole
imaginary axis is going to be tangent
and i can therefore do some reasoning
from there right just so you know by the
way that i'm not just doing a completely
circular argument the reason why this is
valid is suppose i made up some other
question or you made up some other
question and i said well suppose um a
was not at two
suppose it was somewhere like say two
root three okay
uh if i put it two root three think
about what triangle o a b would be
o a b would be what kind of triangle
would it be it would be isosceles right
so therefore i wouldn't get an angle of
pi on 3 up here if this is a right angle
pi on 2 then the other two acute angles
are going to have to be pi on 4 right
now if they're pi on 4 this angle here
would not equal the angle in the
alternate segment so therefore this
would not be a tangent so therefore what
i've created is a diagram that looks
like it's got a tangent but that was
just a coincidence and i shouldn't have
done that right so this is what i mean
by i can use the information in the
question to prove something they haven't
explicitly told me even though it looks
kind of like that on the diagram so this
is um this is the reasoning that i've
employed
all right where am i going to go with
that well what i'm going to say is i can
then use this reasoning if i know that
the imaginary axis is a tangent i'm
going to put a line that's horizontal or
in the positive real direction i did
that before to put in that theta angle
if you recall i'm going to use that and
i'm going to know the fact that oopsie
daisy
it's going to pass through the center
because another property that maybe you
had kicking around in the back of your
mind that a tangent is perpendicular to
the radius at the point of contact right
so what you can see over here in this
next diagram i've got
is i've got this right angle happening
in here because i've got a tangent the
imaginary axis i've got this radius that
i've drawn in and i'm drawing it
horizontal i know i can do that because
i know that the imaginary axis is a
tangent okay so it's horizontal off it
goes and it intersects with c
now at this point i'm going to use
some of the reasoning that i saw in some
of the breakout rooms which is that if
you've got this angle up here pi on 3
this is the angle standing at the
circumference on arc a b the one that's
dotted down here okay but you also have
another angle standing on arc a b um
here a c b it's at the center what's the
relationship between this angle a c b
and the angle a z b the angle of the
center
and the angle at the circumference well
hopefully you recall that the angle at
center is twice it's double the angle at
this conference that's standing on the
same
excuse me standing on the same arc so
therefore i just need to we'll double
that to get its value so that's two pi
on three that you can see
in there okay
now at this point right i've done a lot
of sort of um
preliminary reasoning i i'm like how do
i use this to find the center i
mentioned before that i had many methods
for this um from from all of this
reasoning it kind of breaks off into
several branches i'm going to use this
reasoning as a foundation and i'm going
to show you three methods that come just
from this particular foundation okay
a method
i'm going to call this method 1a because
it comes out of method 1.
i'm going to say let's use some right
angle triangle trig we've already been
doing this a fair bit right
so what i'm going to do is try and
establish some right angles in here that
are going to be useful to me
for starters i already know that i've
got oac
which is pi on 2 like i said i've got
this uh tangent perpendicular to the
radius so i'm going to chuck in a right
angle there
and i can also say i've got this kind of
weird looking looks it's a trapezium i
guess this weird looking quadrilateral
here which i've got a right angle here
right angle here and then i just worked
out that's 2 pi on 3. so i can use that
to infer what angle c
b o is equal to because the angle sum of
the quadrilateral is just going to be 2
pi so what you can find is that it's
actually equal to pi on 3.
now once i've done that i want to try
and use that information the fact that
i've got let's put it in here
let's use this
pi on 3
up in here i want to use that to try and
locate c this angle here is going to
help me right so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to construct an additional
point on with a triangle to use this
right angle triangle trig that i
mentioned i'm going to construct the
point p directly beneath c but on the
real axis okay so it's going to look
something like this directly beneath c
and then when i collide with the real
axis let's call that
point p okay
so once you know that you can do a bunch
of reasoning for starters you remember
how we said before that this length here
oa is two well i've just created a
rectangle um a c p o
and so opposite sides of rectangle are
equal so that's going to be two there on
cp so therefore i'm going to
state that see daisy
like i said please don't worry about
keeping up with all of the working on
this but maybe you just want to write
down cp equals two onto your diagram i
think that will be sufficient
and then if you look closely right this
triangle c p o
you know everything that you need to
know about this diagram to find out the
center right think about this
um for instance i can say number one
i've already kind of got the centers
vertical coordinate right so in order to
work out its horizontal coordinate all i
need to do is is this length over here
and i can infer that by working out this
length over here so i can work out op by
working out
bp right which is inside this new right
angle triangle let me just highlight it
to make it a little more obvious to you
this is the triangle i'm going to be
dealing with in here
in addition to working out what this
length is bp which will give me the
coordinates of the center i can also
work out just using right angle triangle
trig this hypotenuse here bc right
because i've got a side i've got an
angle and i can just use the appropriate
relationship right so that's what i'm
going to do right now i'm going to say
well in this triangle bcp that i just
highlighted in green
i can say i know i know oopsie daisy i
know this side here which is opposite
the angle and i want this side here
which is the hypotenuse right so
opposite hypotenuse what's the
appropriate ratio of course it's going
to be sine so that gives me sine of cpb
equals this particular ratio and from
there it's pretty straightforward to
work out uh what that length is going to
be just by rearranging and doing your
algebra right
so bc is going to be once you um you
know take the negative reciprocal um you
get four on root three which i know some
of you got in the breakouts and i just
rationalize that to get four root three
on three so there's the radius i'm done
right
as i mentioned to get the center um we
can just do some logic with this bp
length here so i'm just going to need a
different trig ratio to get there it's
the adjacent side to that same pi on 3.
so instead i'm just going to use 10
right and this reasoning i hope will
seem familiar once you've gone and done
that in that triangle you find
that this length in here bp is going to
be equal to this 2 root 3 on 3.
how do you use that to find the center
and its coordinates right well if you
know let's have a look here if you know
what this length is in here right 2 root
3 on 3 you already know what this length
is
this larger length because that's ob
which you can get from the coordinates
of b it's just going to be 2 root 3. so
in order to find the coordinates of c i
need to know this horizontal length here
so i just take the difference between
these two purple distances does that
make sense
op can be found by saying op plus pb
equals 2 root 3. so that's what i've
done just below here
you can see i do this subtraction so op
is going to be 4 root 3 on 3 o p right
whoopsie daisy i keep coming back to my
laser pointer op is 4 3 and 3. you can
just do that by subtraction in here and
that pretty much tells you the
coordinates i already knew vertically it
was in line with 2i so therefore
that's my conclusion uh horizontally i
go 4 root 3 on 3 and then vertically i
go to i
so there you go center radius i'm
finished uh and that was the first
method and in many ways um uh and i have
mrs lisa thanks for this one this is her
solution and that's kind of i think one
of the most straightforward ways using
very very basic knowledge an advanced
student could do almost all this
reasoning themselves